[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Das Wetter ist wunderschön, zumindest war es das bis gerade eben.
Jetzt sind einfach dicke Regenwolken da.
Ich wollt heute grillen, Mensch!
Mir egal, ich grille heute
- egal, ob es regnet.
Ihr wisst ja, wir haben uns The Big Green Egg zugelegt
und ich habe auch schon darauf gegrillt,
bisher allerdings nur mit unserem Freund Dennis.
Der hat mir das Gerät erklärt und ich habe mir gedacht:
Komm, heute grillen wir jetzt endlich mal draußen.
Heute grille ich auch das erste Mal alleine auf The Big Green Egg.
D.h., ich probier's.
Es ist, glaube ich, ganz einfach.
Er hat es mir erklärt
und ich hab gedacht: Komm, ich mach das.
Heute gibt es ein leckeres Menü.
Es fängt jetzt nicht ernsthaft an zu regnen.
Ich wollte jetzt in Outdoor-Küche.
Haben wir einen Schirm? Haben wir einen Schirm?
Ich meine, grillen kann man ja bei jedem Wetter.
Aber ich sage es euch: Gerade eben war noch Sonnenschein da.
Dahinten ist auch blau, nur bei mir hier ist eine fette Wolke.
Ich fühl mich wie in so einem Cartoon. In einem Cartoon …
Hallo! Gerade abstellen, danke!
Der Postbote ist da.
Ich fühle mich gerade wie in so einem Comic-Film.
Ehrlich, ich sag's euch.
Egal, die Regenwolke gehen wieder weg.
Ich habe mir gedacht, wir machen heute ein Menü:
Roastbeef, dazu gibt es einen Couscous-Salat,
einen Erdbeer-Spargel-Salat mit Paprikagemüse.
Ich glaube, es wird auf jeden Fall sehr lecker.
Mir egal, wie das Wetter jetzt mitspielt.
Zuerst einmal werde ich den Grill anschalten,
einheizen und dann geht es auch direkt mit der Zubereitung los.
Er braucht ungefähr eine halbe Stunde, bis er auf Temperatur ist
und in der Zeit bereite alles vor.
Dann sind wir auch ganz fix
und vielleicht erwischt uns der Regen ja auch gar nicht.
Ich hole kurz meine Grillkohle. Die habe ich nämlich drinnen.
Das Gute ist, man muss die Kohle unten, die alte, gar nicht wegnehmen,
sondern schiebt sie an eine Stelle.
Alles, was fein ist, fällt nach unten durch.
Ich habe mich auch bisher, muss ich sagen, immer vom Grillen gedrückt,
weil ich das nicht konnte.
Ich konnte keinen Grill anzünden und dann hat es der Murat immer gemacht.
Er hat immer tonnenweise Grillanzünder benutzt.
Da bin ich dann ein bisschen geruchsempfindlich
und denke mir so: Boah, die ganzen Chemikalien!
Aber ich habe jetzt gelernt, wie es richtig geht.
Man braucht dafür nämlich einfach so einen Looftlighter.
Das Gerät kostet 60 oder 69 € und es lohnt sich wirklich,
denn ich glaube,
Murats 4-5 Flaschen Grillanzünder kosten auch so viel
und so spart man sich einfach das Feuerzeug und Grillanzünder.
Das ist schon sehr gut.
So, jetzt 2 kg Kohle rein.
[Musik]
Einfach bis zur ersten Linie.
Ein weißer Pullover ist auch ganz gut.
Aber ich sag's euch: Der Grill und die Kohle rußen nicht,
denn ich habe gelernt, dass eine gute Kohle nicht rußt.
Daran erkennen wie eine gute Kohle.
Gut! Da sind jetzt auch schöne große und kleine Stückchen mit dabei.
Das ist auch ganz gut und ganz wichtig.
Das muss immer schön durchmischt sein.
Der Grill bleibt somit auch viel, viel länger an.
Die Kohle verglüht nicht sofort
und man hat einfach eine schöne Mischung,
kann eben auch schön die Temperatur halten.
[Musik]
Jetzt hier einfach den Looftlighter immer draufdrücken
und reinhalten, bis die Kohle glüht.
Hört sich an wie mein Föhn.
Nicht zu verwechseln mit einem Föhn!
[Musik]
Wenn die Kohle dann glüht, einfach den Deckel schließen,
hier oben und unten öffnen
[Musik]
und einfach darauf warten, dass der Grill warm wird!
Die Zeit kann man jetzt natürlich nutzen und das Essen vorbereiten.
Hier ist es im Prinzip wie bei einem Hausbrand:
Wenn Sauerstoff reinkommt, werden die Flammen heiß.
Das heißt, jetzt viel Sauerstoff reinlassen
und später reguliere ich dann die Hitze des Grills,
indem ich die Fächer wieder schließe.
Also wie gesagt, heute gibt es Roastbeef,
hatte ich nämlich noch da und Murat hat sich das auch sehr gewünscht.
Und für mich?
Ich habe mir gedacht, ich will eigentlich etwas Vegetarisches,
aber jetzt verknüpfen wir beides,
machen Roastbeef mit einem Couscous-Salat und Spargelgemüse.
Wie gesagt, hier habe ich das Roastbeef, das sind etwa 900 g.
Dann habe ich hier für das Gemüse etwa 400 g grünen Stangenspargel,
1 rote Paprika, 1 Avocado, Frühlingszwiebeln, 1 Limette.
Hier habe ich noch die Erdbeeren
und dafür brauche ich noch Salz, Pfeffer und Olivenöl.
Hier habe ich bereits meinen Couscous, da nehme ich jetzt 250 Gramm,
auch 1 Limette, davon brauche ich Saft und Schale,
und ein bisschen Petersilie.
Dann habe ich noch ein paar Zutaten für die Soße.
Ich mache nämlich so eine Sriracha-Soße.
Sriracha ist im Prinzip so eine scharfe Chili-Soße.
Ihr könnt aber auch alternativ Tabasco nehmen.
Da habe ich ein bisschen Mayonnaise
- die könnt ihr selber zubereiten oder Mayonnaise kaufen.
Sriracha-Soße.
Das Öl war noch für den Couscous.
Tomatenmark, Salz, Pfeffer und Paprikapulver und 1 Knoblauchzehe.
Ich glaube, weil ich sowieso noch ein bisschen Zeit habe,
bereite ich jetzt erst mal die Soße zu.
Die kann ich dann nämlich wieder reinstellen.
Falls es doch gleich anfängt zu regnen,
kann ich nämlich nach drinnen flüchten.
Ich brauche noch den Teigschaber. Warte kurz!
Auch in einer Outdoor-Küche brauchen wir eine Löffelauflage.
Die muss auch sauber bleiben.
Wir machen jetzt erst einmal die Soße.
Dafür die Mayonnaise in ein Schälchen geben.
Ich sage's euch, ich mache es nur für euch.
Ich habe hier auch eine Schüssel für schmutziges Geschirr.
Jetzt die Knoblauchzehe schälen und fein reiben oder einfach pressen.
Ich habe hier so eine asiatische Knoblauchzehe.
Die sehen immer so wie kleine Knoblauchknöllchen aus.
Deswegen ist sie auch so riesig.
Aber ich nehme davon jetzt nur die Hälfte,
sonst haben wir wirklich eine Knoblauchzehe.
So ein bisschen dazu reiben.
[Musik]
Dann Salz, Pfeffer und Paprikapulver mit rein.
Es ist schon schön mit dem Schälchen da unten:
Zack, Geschirr weg!
Dann Tomatenmark und die Soße.
Wenn ihr gerne scharf esst,
nehmt ruhig 2 EL, ansonsten nur 1 EL.
Bei mir müssen jetzt alle scharf essen.
[Musik]
Dann wäre die Soße schon einmal fertig.
Beim Fleisch denkt ihr auch einfach dran,
dass ihr es schon 1-2 Stunden vor der Zubereitung
aus dem Kühlschrank nehmt,
damit das Fleisch gut auf Temperatur kommen kann,
denn dann wird es auch schön fein und wird nicht zäh.
Denn wenn man ganz kaltes Fleisch direkt auf eine heiße Flamme legt
oder eben auch anbrät oder im Backofen zubereitet, wird's zäh.
Deswegen immer erst einmal auf Temperatur kommen lassen.
Die Soße ist fertig.
Dann kümmere ich mich um den Spargel.
Die Paprika und die Spargel werde ich jetzt gleich grillen.
Beim grünen Spargel ist der Vorteil, dass man den ich schälen muss.
D.h., hier unten könnt ihr einfach nur
das trockene Ende ein bisschen wegbrechen.
Dann ist er schon bereit.
Wenn er ganz frisch vom Bauern gekauft ist,
dann hat er oftmals gar keine trockenen Enden.
Dann könnt ihr sie einfach so lassen.
Ich empfehle euch da auch immer,
das Ganze wegzubrechen und nicht zu schneiden,
weil der Spargel genau da bricht,
wo praktisch das holzige trockene Ende aufhört
und dann schneidet man nicht aus Versehen zu viel weg.
[Musik]
Ich sehe jetzt hier auch schon,
dass der Grill relativ schnell heiß wird.
Sobald er die 200°C überstiegen hat,
werde ich jetzt hier auch schon einmal
die Klappe bis zur Hälfte verschließen, unten genauso.
[Musik]
Jetzt sehe ich auch gleich, dass die Temperatur sich einregelt
und ich will jetzt gleich beim Fleisch so bei ungefähr 180°C landen.
Hier oben kann ich das Ganze feinjustieren.
Das wird jetzt gleich ein bisschen abfallen und dann sehe ich,
dass ich die Temperatur gleich einstellen kann.
Deswegen braucht er noch ganz kurz.
Das habe ich jetzt aber schon mal bereit.
Das Fleisch steht bereit.
Dann kann ich hier schon einmal die Zwiebel fein hacken.
Diese ist für den Salat.
[Musik]
Da nehme ich hier jetzt noch die Avocado.
Ihr könnt ihr oben übrigens diesen Strunk entfernen.
Und wenn sie hier im Inneren schön grün ist, dann ist sie perfekt.
Sie sollte auf jeden Fall so ein bisschen weich sein.
Wenn sie da schon braun ist, dann ist sie schon überreif.
Dann kann es sein, dass sie nicht mehr so schön grün ist.
Und jetzt halbieren.
Aufdrehen. Guckt mal, wie schön.
Den Kern entfernen.
Dann mache ich so, dass ich sie jetzt einfach hier würfle.
Aber wirklich nicht die Schale durchschneiden,
sondern nur anritzen - auf die Hände aufpassen!
[Musik]
Dann könnte nämlich mit dem Löffel einfach die Würfel rausnehmen.
Dann jetzt hier direkt auch den Limettensaft dazugeben,
damit die Avocado nicht braun wird.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr möchtet, auch schon die Erdbeeren vierteln und dazuzugeben.
[Singend] ♪ I'm cooking in the rain … ♪
Es ist ja nicht so,
als hätte ich eine große Küche, hier drinnen, im Haus, überdacht.
Egal, ich finde es cool.
Okidoki, dann steht hier erst einmal alles für den Salat bereit.
Wie gesagt, hier fehlen nur noch die Spargelstangen und die Paprika.
Dann nehme ich das einmal hier raus
und kann in dieser Schüssel den Couscous anrühren.
Der kommt da rein und da kommt jetzt die doppelte Menge Wasser dazu.
Das Wasser sollte natürlich kochen.
Das hole ich ganz kurz und übergieße es nämlich einfach nur.
Beim Reinlaufen nehme ich Geschirr mit.
[Musik]
Dann direkt abdecken.
Hier kann ich noch die Petersilie fein hacken.
[Musik]
Zur Peterselie gebe ich noch den Limettenabrieb dazu.
Es macht auch nichts,
wenn noch ein bisschen Knoblauch an der Reibe dran ist.
Dann haben wir so einen leichten Knoblauchgeschmack noch im Couscous.
Das passt auch sehr gut.
Das Rezept können ihr natürlich auch,
wenn ihr jetzt einen Grill habt und nicht draußen grillen wollt,
ganz easy drinnen machen.
Aber ich habe mir gedacht: Komm, ich verlagere die Küche nach draußen,
denn der Grill ist eigentlich nicht nur ein Grill,
sondern wirklich eigentlich ein komplettes Kochgerät.
Also ich kann darin auch kochen, garen und alles Mögliche zubereiten.
Deswegen finde ich, wenn man es dann schon hat,
sollte man es auch komplett nutzen.
So, den Saft presse ich auch gleich in den Couscous dazu,
aber der darf jetzt erst einmal kurz ein bisschen stehen
So, die Temperatur regelt sich gerade.
Dann sehen wir uns gleich, wenn der Grill auf 180°C Geheizt ist.
Wisst ihr was?
Ich bediene mich noch an meinem Garten.
Ich habe hier noch ein bisschen Sauerampfer wachsen,
dann nehmen wir jetzt noch ein paar Blätter dazu.
Sauerampfer ist sehr, sehr lecker und sehr gesund.
Ich mag es auch ganz gerne morgens aufs Brot,
einfach mit ein bisschen Salz oder pur.
Die Kinder essen es auch ganz gerne pur;
hat einfach einen schönen säuerlichen Geschmack
und passt hervorragend in Salaten,
man kann auch Suppen daraus zubereiten.
Also ein richtig leckeres Salatblatt.
[Musik]
Jetzt hat mein Grill die perfekte Temperatur
und ich habe hier diese verschiedenen Einsätze;
die sind auch sehr variabel, muss ich sagen.
Die kommen jetzt hier rein.
Jetzt ist ja noch alles kalt, deswegen kann ich es noch so anfassen.
Aber jetzt lasse ich erst einmal hier den Rost warm werden.
Sobald der Rost dann warm ist,
lege ich das Fleisch drauf auf die Gusseisenseite.
und brate das Fleisch dann rundherum erstmal schön braun an
und lass es dann später bei indirekter Hitze noch weiter garen.
In der Zeit werde ich dann auch schon den Spargel und die Paprika garen
und kann aber, so lange das hier noch ganz kurz aufheizt,
auf jeden Fall den Salat fertigstellen.
Der ist jetzt schön durchgezogen.
Schaut mal - kurz den Couscous lockern!
Man könnte hier die Petersilie und Limette dazu geben.
[Musik]
Und auch gerne den Sauerampfer, den schneid ich auch ganz fein.
Dann schmeckt ihr das Ganze mit Olivenöl und mit dem Limettensaft ab.
[Musik]
Aber uns ist es hier schon sehr laut für einen Dreh,
muss ich schon sagen.
Man hat immer entweder die B 36 oder den Zug
oder die LKW oder die Motorräder.
[Musik]
So, dann wäre der Couscous jetzt auch bereit
und ich kann das Fleisch drauflegen.
[Musik]
Den Spargel gare ich jetzt auch schon einmal hier.
Und die Paprika.
[Musik]
Beim Spargel natürlich ab und zu wenden.
Also den hier nicht vergessen.
Er braucht so ungefähr 5-8 Min.
[Musik]
Der Spargel und die Paprika sind fertig,
das Fleisch braucht noch ein bisschen.
Das wird jetzt schon einmal gewendet
und dann lass ich es gleich indirekt weiter garen.
Guck mal, was ich hier bei der Paprika so faszinierend finde:
Normalerweise ist es ja so,
dass die Paprika auf jedem anderen Grill
einfach ganz, ganz trocken wird.
Aber hier, schaut mal!
Hier habt ihr das ganze Wasser,
die ganze Feuchtigkeit der Paprika noch im Innern.
Sieht man das?
[Musik]
Das Fleisch setze ich jetzt einfach ein bisschen höher
und lasse es jetzt noch schön weiter garn.
Ich habe jetzt noch einen Thermometer mit drin.
Dann kann ich es besser kontrollieren
und im Prinzip eigentlich sogar fast komplett verschließen.
Das kann jetzt hier noch schön durchziehen.
Wie gesagt, sieht man hier bei der Paprika ganz gut,
dass sie wirklich schön feucht ist und sie einfach …
Ja, sie ist einfach schön saftig
und das möchte ich jetzt natürlich in meinem Salat mit drin haben.
Ich habe jetzt auch dieses schöne Räucheraroma.
[Musik]
Bei der Paprika habe ich auch die Haut so ein bisschen abgezogen.
Die kommt jetzt hier mit zum Salat.
Der Spargel genauso.
[Musik]
Jetzt hier nur noch mit Salz, Pfeffer und Olivenöl abschmecken
und dann ist alles gleich soweit,
sobald das Fleisch fertig ist.
Ich mache es ja auch gar nicht groß eine Marinade dazu,
denn ich finde,
herade beim Grillen sollte man die Lebensmittel so belassen,
wie sie eben auch gut schmecken.
Ich habe hier jetzt den schönen Geschmack der geräucherten Paprika.
Ich habe den Stangenspargel.
Ich habe die Avocado noch mit dabei,
so ein bisschen Säure durch die Limette
und jetzt einen schönen Olivenölgeschmack.
Die Soße, die sie Sriracha-Mayonnaise.
gibt ja dann noch einmal einen Extrageschmack dazu.
[Musik]
Ich bin so richtig happy,
denn ich kontrolliere die Fleischtemperatur einfach über einen Thermometer.
Ich muss auch sagen, ich muss es immer mit dem Thermometer machen.
Ich bin jetzt da nicht die Expertin,
die sagt, ich drücke da drauf und gucke mal, wie es ist.
Ich bin ein Kontrollfreak.
Ich kontrolliere es dann lieber, habe jetzt hier 54°C
und man sieht ja auf den Thermometer auch ganz gut:
Erst war es Rare, dann Medium Rare,
Jetzt bin ich bei Medium.
Ich werde jetzt demnächst runternehmen, so bei 56°C.
Es war bisher ein echt sehr entspanntes Grillen.
Ich habe meine Beilagen, das Fleisch und die Soße zubereitet.
Hallo Yoshi! Hey Simi!
Und jetzt sind wir im Prinzip gleich fertig.
Gleich hauen wir noch ein paar Rinderspieße drauf.
MURAT: Endlich mal ein Grill,
womit dir dann auch gerecht wird, oder? [Sally bejaht]
Normalerweise, so kenne ich es von meinen Freunden,
egal, ob Türke, Deutscher, Italiener:
Da machen die Frauen meistens die Beilagen
und die Männer sind am Grill.
SALLY: Ja, aber ich lasse doch nicht das, was ich vorbereite.
von dir kaputt grillen.
MURAT: Jetzt hast du mir das auch noch weggenommen.
Jetzt denken sich die Zuschauer da draußen und sagen:
Was macht er eigentlich?
SALLY: Er isst und er macht den Boden sauber.
MURAT: Ja, ich bin übrigens auf dem Bau.
SALLY: Warte, ich mache es kurz auf.
Beim Öffnen übrigens immer vorsichtig,
also immer ganz kurz öffnen
- das gilt für jeden Kugelgrill -
und dann komplett öffnen.
Ich habe jetzt auch noch einmal zwischenzeitlich
ein bisschen Spargel draufgelegt,
aber das Fleisch sieht jetzt perfekt aus.
Ich nehme es jetzt vom Grill runter.
[Musik]
Ja, heute ist das ganze Team mit.
Deswegen habe ich noch ein bisschen was vorbereitet.
MURAT: Für Veganer ist grüner Spargel ein genialer Fleischersatz, finde ich.
Grüner Spargel ist meiner Meinung nach das Beste.
SALLY: Ja, vor allem einfach vom Grill
mit ein bisschen Olivenöl, Salz, Pfeffer …
MURAT: Balsamico drüber.
SALLY: … Balsamico - das reicht schon.
Das packe ich noch da drauf und dann können wir gleich probieren.
[Musik]
MURAT: Darf ich ein Foto für meine Instagram-Seite machen? [Sally bejaht]
Bitte! Oder ich schicke es dann an meine Kumpels
und die drehen dann total durch.
SALLY: Ist sowieso immer besser, wenn man das Fleisch kurz liegen lässt,
damit es sich vor dem Anschnitt entspannen kann.
Okay?
Ich hatte mir ursprünglich überlegt, eine Bowl anzurichten.
Könnt ihr auch gerne machen.
Ach komm, wir machen eine Bowl.
Holst du mal 2 Schüsseln? [Murat bejaht]
Oder soll ich sie dir auf dem Teller zubereiten? [Murat bejaht]
Okay, für dich mache ich es auf den Teller.
Das ist Sauerampfer-Limetten-Couscous.
Sauerampfer wächst bei uns im Garten.
MURAT: Haust du ihn aus unserem Garten geholt? [Sally bejaht]
Erdbeeren haben wir auch eigentlich normalerweise
dahinten bei diesen Hängetrögen.
Und hier haben wir überall Troibele (Trauben) belegt.
Äpfel und Birnen haben wir auch.
Überall sind Kräuter hier im ganzen Garten.
Das ist übrigens unser Kräutergarten.
Den haben wir von der Sonner her so ausgelegt,
dass hier immer die Abendsonne ist. [Sally stimmt zu]
[Musik]
SALLY: Dann probier mal!
MURAT: Soll ich mal probieren? [Sally bejaht]
Noch ein bisschen groben Salz.
SALLY: Der Grill hält übrigens 23 Stunden lang die Temperatur.
Also ich könnte jetzt noch ganz gechillt weiter grillen
oder ich kann ihn einfach ausmachen, indem ich die Klappe verschließe.
Probiere mal noch den Couscous und die Soße!
Schmeckt's? [Murat bejaht]
MURAT: Ist das Ajvar?
SALLY: Nein, ich habe eine Sriracha-Soße gemacht, aus dieser scharfen …
MURAT: Gesundheit!
SALLY: [Lacht] … aus dieser scharfen Chili-Soße mit Mayonnaise.
Im Prinzip ist auch alles vegan.
D.h., Benny kann auch mit essen, nur eben das Fleisch nicht,
aber alle anderen Sachen sind vegan.
MURAT: Hast du die Maharadscha-Soße selber gemacht?
SALLY: [Lacht] Also zusammengemischt.
Sriracha-Soße, Mayonnaise, noch Gewürze.
MURAT: Die ist der Hammer, wirklich!
Hast du schon einmal überlegt, so eine Soße selber zu machen?
SALLY: Hä? Ich habe die selber gemacht.
Ich habe nur die Mayonnaise nicht selber zubereitet.
MURAT: Ich würde in dich investieren für 50 % deiner Anteile.
SALLY: Ach meinst du so wie …
Wie heißt der Gangster, der mit seiner Pizza?
MURAT: Mmh!!
Capital Bra.
SALLY: Ach ja, genau.
So wie Capital Bra seine Gangster-Pizza hat,
mache ich eine Sally-Soße.
Boah! Die Soße ist echt der Hammer!
Okay, also ich wünsche euch viel Spaß beim Nachbacken.
Ach, Nachbacken sage ich schon.
Viel Spaß beim Grillen. Probiert das Rezept gerne aus.
Ich hole jetzt noch unser Team,
grill hier noch fertig für alle
und dann essen wir das hier gemeinsam.
Ich schreibe euch natürlich das Rezept in die App
und wünsche euch viel Spaß dabei.
Ich hatte jedenfalls sehr viel Spaß dabei,
jetzt einmal endlich ein Outdoor-Grillen zu machen
und somit die Grillsaison für uns zu eröffnen.
Ich muss auch sagen, dass ich jetzt endlich, da ich
einen gescheiten Grill habe,
auch die Grillsaison das ganze Jahr über halten werde,
wenn es mir nicht zu kalt wird.
MURAT: Echt genial!
Und wie gesagt, es muss nicht immer Fleisch sein. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Heute war Fleisch eigentlich fast nur die Beilage.
MURAT: Aber wenn es doch Fleisch ist …
SALLY: Dann ist es einfach so!
MURAT: Dann ist es auch toll!
SALLY: Also viel Spaß beim Nachmachen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
BEIDE: Tschüss!
MURAT: Du bist jetzt voll der Checker!
SALLY: Ich habe es dir jahrelang gesagt:
Hol mir einfach einen gescheiten Grill.
Dann mache ich mehr Grillrezepte.
Jetzt habe ich endlich einen Grill.
Pizza vom Grill ist auch sehr lecker!
MURAT: Du weißt aber, was der gekostet hat, oder?
SALLY: Aber der lohnt sich jetzt.
MURAT: Dafür habe ich dann …
SALLY: Ich grille das ganze Jahr über.
MURAT: Weißt du, wie oft ich Blut spenden musste, um den Grill zu holen?
SALLY: Ich habe deine Nieren verkauft! [Beide lachen]
Ciao!
[Musik]